etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
sein video ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut ja auch eigentlich nicht eigentlich
also schon ich bin mal gespannt was uns
im heutigen video erwartet weil ich habe
logischerweise selber auch noch keinen
plan ich
kann ich euch das erzählt also ich habe
vor einiger zeit mehr ins heim nacht
bekomme ich würde sagen ich lasse euch
mal den chartverlauf vor und dann habe
ich mit dem so einen kleinen deal
verhandelt und er hat mir dann etwas
geschick und ja das ist jetzt angekommen
und wir sitzen hier um es auf zu machen
alex ich schaue sehr oft deine unboxing
videos und findest du immer sehr
unterhaltsam wenn du sachen auspackt und
ich darüber ärgert oder auch nicht hey
danke übrigens dass du es unterhaltsam
findet wenn ich mich über etwas ärgern
ich finde es nicht unterhaltsam ich habe
mich schon so oft weil irgendwelchen
unboxing videos so geärgert das hab ich
dann halt nie hoch geladen weil die
sachen immer scheiße waren haben dass
wir kommen gar nicht ich dachte mir
vielleicht kann ich dir für ein weiteres
video zur seite stehen dafür ist es aber
wichtig dass du meinen namen nicht nennt
und bitte zensiert ich könnte es
ernsthafte probleme bekommen es geht um
ware von media markt möglich gern mal
gruß aus bayern ich muss erst mal
vorneweg sagen ich krieg so oft solche
nachricht oder so ähnliche nachrichten
wo mir leute irgendwie dann so rest post
andrehen wollen die sagen und alex ist
mit 500 euro und da ist wahren wert von
1200 euro drin habe ich einmal
vielleicht gemacht und seitdem nie
wieder aber hier weiß jetzt was anderes
ich habe mir mein erzähl mir gerne mal
mehr und klar du brauchst du echt keine
sorgen machen ich zensiere das alles
versprochen habe ich ihn natürlich
verarscht wie ihr sehen könnt ist alles
nicht zensiert natürlich sehe ich das
alles ist es mir wichtig nicht dass der
kollege seinen job verliert so weiter
geht es also ich arbeite so zu sagen bei
media markt und habe dort auch oft was
mit den räten zu tun das meiste wird
natürlich direkt wieder an den
ladenverkauf gebracht einiges aber auch
nicht das hat oft verschiedene gründe
ich denke ich könnte es organisieren dir
mal ein paket zusammenzustellen das wird
sich sicher lohnen für dich mit geld
dahinter und dann sind bei mir natürlich
die alarmglocken angegangen ich habe
geschrieben klingt eigentlich echt
interessant hh können wir gerne machen
ha ha für wie viel geld würdest du denn
so was zusammenstellen haare helle die
leute die immer so hh dahinter schreiben
obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht witzig
ist wenn es in ordnung geht würde ich
150 euro vorschlagen falls es sie dann
gefällt können wir auch mehr geld
ausmachen plus dann den versand ja und
so weiter ich habe immer letztendlich
160 euro geschickt und er hat mir ein
paket zusammengestellt und ich habe echt
keine ahnung was mich da jetzt erwartet
so weit ich das beurteilen kann ist es
auch bei media markt üblich dass das
meiste wirklich wieder einfach in den
ladenverkauf geht so wie er auch gesagt
hat und die verkaufen sicherlich auch
auftritte oder restposten großen mengen
dann so ab an irgendwelche
weiterverkäufer ins ausland ich weiß es
nicht ganz genau aber irgendwas muss ja
irgendwann musste ja für zuständig sein
dass das passiert und ich denke das sind
jetzt einfach irgendwelche retouren die
hoffentlich viel wert sind also 160
bezahlt wir schauen einfach mal oder ich
bin gespannt bei den warmen temperaturen
heute können wir ruhig mal die jacke
ausziehen oder ok ich bin wie immer ein
bisschen nervös vielleicht also ich muss
noch mal sagen ich bin mega projekt von
dir dass du das machst weil viele würden
das denke ich nicht machen ich habe auch
alles was auf dich hinweisen könnte
schon runter gemacht hier das ab und so
kannst du vertrauen okay machen wir es
mal auf 160 euro für das ganze paket ist
jetzt menschheit messer haben kann also
für 160 euro ist das eigentlich echt
schwer ich bin positiv gestimmt und für
die die sich fragen was ich eigentlich
im fresh ist apple watch band room habe
das ist von apfel band und die sponsern
das heute gewesen leute was geht ab ich
bin gerade hier spazieren bei mir im
park ist dirk neben beim büro und das
heutige video wird gesponsert von apfel
band ich habe mir gerade auch meine
apple watch an und das ganze kombiniert
mit einem armband von apfel bahn ihr
könnt gerne mal die seite abchecken ich
bremse auch hier mal ein auf jeden fall
gibt es auf der absehbaren website ganz
ganz viele verschiedene arm männer für
männer und frauen ganz viele
verschiedene styles lederarmbänder
silikon am ende was auch immer ich habe
mir meine ferien zum aussuchen dürfen
und die kann man halt ganz einfach
wechseln ich zeige euch mal wie einfach
das ist leute ohne dass das ganze jetzt
hoffentlich nicht ins wasser fällt aber
das ist gerade wirklich ein bisschen
crazy was ich hier mache ihr könnt hier
hinten einfach auf diese knöpfe drücken
und ganz einfach die armbänder
rausziehen und halten mit neuen
kombinieren ich muss sagen ich finde das
echt nice weil neben meinen anderen
grund trage ich mir doch sehr auf die
apple watch und dann hat man einfach mal
ja quasi eine ganz neue uhr am
handgelenk und vom spaziergang bei dem
schönen wetter wieder zurück in mein
büro wertes gedacht ich habe natürlich
auch noch einen code für euch und zwar
gibt es mit alex w 15 15 prozent rabatt
auf alle produkte und das geile ist
aktuell ist noch bis zum 18 april spring
sale das heißt noch mal zusätzlich 20
rabatt wenn ihr glück habt gibt es also
insgesamt 35 cent rabatt das game ab
leute und wir machen weiter mit dem
video strohleute dann würde ich sagen
metzger links
rechtsgrund hier sagt
okay ich weiß übrigens leute dass das
jetzt nicht das heftigste unboxing wird
ja aber ich habe zum beispiel gestern
was neues einsteiger taschen im wert von
25.000 euro dass wir wirklich geistes
kann aber ich glaube es lohnt sich
trotzdem das video auf dem hauptkanal zu
bringen wir starten erst mal hier mit
hier haben wir eine einen samsung
backcover dass es halt bisschen lärm so
dann haben wir hier noch mehr davon und
hier noch 11 03 keine ahnung wie sind
zusammen vielleicht 25 euro sagt dann
machen wir weiter ich würde sagen hier
mit als nächstes haben wir hier der ist
das schon ein bisschen brocken aber ich
hoffe noch in einem guten zustand ein
panasonic rasierer und ich bin mir
eigentlich sicher so wie ich das jetzt
einschätzen würde diesem gerät und
diesem ding was ihr gerade nicht sehen
können diese 160 euro eigentlich schon
wieder raus das ist schon mal so vielen
dank derer einmal einen rasierer
eigentlich alles noch gut eingepackt
eine ahnung panasonic der kostet
bestimmt 70 euro schauen wir mal nach
was haben wir denn hier legal etf auf
ebay einfach das dingen 134 euro 85
wobei ich mir jetzt eigentlich nicht
vorstellen kann aber amazon habe ich
denn für 1 60 euro gefunden was trotzdem
ganz gut ist also rasierer 1 60 euro
kann man vermeiden ist ein guter start
heute haben wir auch nicht so viele
produkte das heißt ich suche mir euch
das ganze hier unten in der ecke mal auf
müssen wir jetzt gerade bei circa 86
euro seien weiter geht's als nächstes
haben wir hier ein headset okay das
halbzeit ist von ist einfach ein xbox
headset und ja keine ahnung preis steht
leider nicht dran sind aber noch in dem
das ist sogar noch originalverpackt egal
ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was das
genau für sachen sind und wie es
zustande kommen weil hier wunder ich
mich jetzt dass das original verpackt
ist oder zumindest ganz mal aufmachen
aber damit wird das denkmal nix seien
sie doch wunderbar aus 6 ab weil sie
nicht so ein headset brauche ich will
mal schätzen irgendwie nur 40 euro kann
man dafür bestimmt nehmen was sagt mein
scanner damit 44 eur 44 ja auch nicht
schlecht also leute es läuft es läuft es
läuft wir haben doch eigentlich jetzt
schon fast die 160 euro drin und ich
habe ich sehe hier noch einige ist also
ihr könnt mir gern man doch nach oben da
lassen wenn ich dem kollegen nur sagen
soll ja komm ich geb dir mal 1000 euro
macht da mal was weiß nicht ob das macht
so keine ahnung bei ich habe zum
beispiel einmal so ein video gemacht hat
mir dann amazon produkttester ware
zukommen lassen und er hat danach so rum
geheult und alex kannst dass du dich
doch bitte wieder offline nehmen wir
haben so viele leute in irgendwelchen
foren geschrieben dann dachte ich immer
dicker das ist mir doch bitte erst gar
nicht was ist das hier eigentlich auch
das sieht aber schon mal benutzt aus
oder zumindest die das duo setzt welche
schon mal was drin gewesen ja das trifft
auch nicht so gut das finde ich immer
sind die schlimmsten die kaufen sich
fast fühlen da was rein und schicken es
dann wieder zurück also das muss ich auf
jeden fall einmal durch waschen wir
haben in den ergo mix von bosch was
kostet so ein denken die leute ich habe
keine ahnung also damit kann ich mich
überhaupt nicht auskennen wir mal und
102 euro hast also ich muss sagen die
wehr preise sind schon immer relativ
hoch und ich werde dafür sicherlich
nicht 102 euro bekommen hier steht sogar
noch was von mediamarkt drauf schaut
noch drei jahre plus 14 99 also wir sind
jetzt auf jeden fall schon bei über 200
euro zweiter gedanke für die folie also
dass du vor dir eingepackt das hat
unfassbar für gebracht die ware konnte
gar nicht hin und her wackeln wir haben
hier noch als nächstes aeg ja das ist da
von denen hatte ich schon mal ein
staubsauger honka und kid also das ist
jetzt hier nur zubehör kostet irgendwas
zwischen 20 und 30 euro schein jahr 30
euro wenn es gut läuft okay und jetzt
geht es aber weiter dann haben wir hier
noch zwei webcams einmal eine
playstation webcam da habe ich mich ja
letztens mal irgendwo gefragt auf meinem
zweiten kanal war das glaube ich warum
ist sowas überhaupt gibt und haben wir
sogar noch ein preisschild 335 euro das
heißt das war wahrscheinlich schon beim
laden keine ahnung weiter geht's mit
einer nächsten webcam die hier ist von
trotz auch nicht schlecht scheint auch
noch ungeöffnet also dinger echt mies
korrekt dass du mir geschrieben hast
also hier habe ich die neue für 42 und
dann haben wir zu guter letzt ja mir tut
ein bisschen leid das war es irgendwie
leider schon das ist jetzt leider das
letzte produkt aber ich glaube auch das
teuerste einen google maps audio also
alexa von google ist das nicht gönne ich
mir auch mal kurz ein ja scheiße da
hätte ich jetzt gedacht das wäre ein
bisschen teurer 64 eur 90 also ihr könnt
jetzt schon hier sehen ich muss mir
jetzt kurz mal sammelt das ein mal
zusammenrechnen aber hey das hat dich so
krass gelohnt also die 160 euro habe ich
auf jeden fall mehr als alles fast
verdreifacht für zweieinhalbfache
ungefähr ist schon echt stark starke
leistung hätte ich nicht endlich muss
ich sagen hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet
ich hab es natürlich gehofft aber ich
wurde auch schon so oft enttäuscht
deswegen freut mich das natürlich ne
also weiter ich habe jetzt gerade noch
mal alles zusammengerechnet und wir
kommen auf insgesamt 367 euro was auf
jeden fall echt ein stabiler wert ist
alles realistische preise also ich habe
jetzt nie die höchsten wie immer habe
ich ja schon oftmals erklärt wie ich das
dann zusammen rechne also ich werde auf
jeden fall am start noch mal ein
bisschen mehrwert überzeugen mal gucken
was da noch so drin ist lassen wir gerne
daumen nach oben da wenn ich das machen
soll oder ich weiß nicht vielleicht
klappt es doch gar nicht werden sehen
ansonsten könnt ihr euch wirklich auf
die nächsten videos freuen die werden
glaube ich schon echt bild und ja danke
leute bis zu schauen das kann doch nach
oben check up verband ab die machen echt
coole sachen und wir sehen uns haut rein